this is the battlefield of the Ukrainian
Southern counter-attack on Kirsten and
this is a nasty battle
many liberated towns like Visa copula
have been wrecked everywhere you look
buildings are destroyed cars and vans
litter the roads burnt out and smashed
after weeks of fighting and shelling and
that never stops
Ukrainian casualties from the front line
a few miles away are brought back and
hurriedly put into ambulances the
casualty figures for both sides is high
the Russians said they would never leave
the residents who stayed or have
returned speak of living in fear and
more importantly of systematic
widespread looting
they dismissed the concept of a
referendum for joining Russia as
absolutely ridiculous
on the road the Russians retreated down
a burnt out van was filled with
motorbikes thought to have been stolen
they didn't get away
beaudan says that was absolutely
standard procedure for the Russian
soldiers
sir
Australia
I think is
the area hospital was used by the
Russians as their headquarters it's
destroyed and it's empty now
ukrainians have pushed them out but this
battle isn't over well the ukrainians
have taken back this town and they're
holding it for certain but it seems to
be a big difference to me between
actually physically being here and
actually saying this is now part of
Ukraine
the Russians are only about five
kilometers up the road here
um soldiers here as you can imagine
there's a couple who have returned
and they're heading towards an area
where a referendum is being held on
weather
just five kilometers away should become
Russia as opposed to Ukraine and of
course what it is there it's bizarre
but uh yes they're here but it doesn't
feel like it's very held at all
Bellagio was part of a group who buried
people during the Russian occupation and
the battles here
he brought 13 to the cemetery in a
trailer and bury them by himself
he told us that the dead were often the
elderly but he revealed one family was
targeted and murdered by Russian
soldiers
few will get over this war
the Ukrainian determination to build
from this Victory and to take Curson
back collides with President Putin's
plans to escalate this conflict
many more communities will be wrecked
like this one
there is no end in sight
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Southern Ukraine